[Music]
they might not be related by blood but
hopper and eleven have a father-daughter
relationship if we've ever seen one with
the way things left off in season two
it's obvious that hopper is going to
have a lot of work on his hands watch
until the end to find out if hopper and
Elevens relationship will survive what
the upside down has in store for them
first time the things don't forget to
hit that subscribe button for more
amazing content to come your way and if
you like stranger things as much as we
do make sure to give this video a big
thumbs up now let's find out what hopper
and eleven have been up to since we last
saw them a happy home all eleven ever
wanted was to be accepted for who she
really was
and while she might have believed that
dr. brenner loved her more than he did
his practice she was wrong after
escaping from the Hawkins laboratory she
found herself amidst a solid friend
group one that didn't want to exploit
her for her kinetic powers unfortunately
for her dr. Brenner was nowhere near
close to letting her go which caused a
series of unfortunate events to spring
forward for unknown reasons hopper saw
something in eleven that caused him to
become protective over her their
connection was so strong that he
eventually became her guardian and
risked his life to save hers on more
than one account at the end of season
two we clearly see dr. Owens handing
hopper an envelope and most of us were
surprised to see that the envelope
contained a forged birth certificate
claiming that hopper was 11th biological
father
congratulations pops so with this in
mind we're convinced that season 3 will
grant 11 her first real home experience
this theory places hopper and 11 in a
happy home one where hopper raises her
as though she was his very own child
according to the birth certificate
Elevens name will be changed to Jane
hopper however dr. Rowan stressed the
importance of keeping a low profile for
about a year so with this in mind we
don't foresee 11 attending Hawkins
middle school anytime soon laying low
most of us felt sorry for Elevens dodgy
lifestyle in season 2 despite having
defeated most of her enemies the poor
girl was still on the run which led her
to live in hoppers grandfather's Shack
for about a year while under hoppers
eleven had a set of simple rules to
follow most of which she chose to break
11 was encouraged to keep the curtains
drawn cut all contact with the outside
world and refrain from opening the door
to strangers then you take that off sit
down and eat your foods getting cold
despite being safe and sound the
solitude got to eleven quicker than
hopper had expected causing their
relationship to take a hit while it's
been stated that eleven will become
hoppers natural daughter in season three
dr. Owens did stress the importance of
keeping a low profile so knowing this
we're afraid that eleven will have to go
back to the shack for another year while
she may have been instructed to lay low
there's no controlling the gifted
preteen however from the looks of things
hopper has no intention of keeping her
from her friends despite having to lay
low for another little while hopper and
eleven seemed to be more than happy with
the news we're hoping that 11 or should
we save Jane will be able to rekindle
her friendship with Mike will Lucas and
Dustin while keeping a low profile at
the same time the lost sister eleven
might have been the most powerful child
to step foot in the hulking slab but she
wasn't the only one in season two eleven
discovers while tapping into her
mother's mind that there was a girl
named Kali with her in the Hawkins lab
wanting to make a familial connection
she locates her and leaves for Chicago
at first light are you real is surreal
after rekindling their relationship and
swapping sob stories Kali welcomes 11
into her gang of degenerates where she
is later forced to unleash her powers on
those who experimented on her as a child
despite wanting to fit in with a gang xi
realizes that she doesn't have enough
hate in her heart to kill later on while
getting ambushed by police officers 11
gets a vision that places mike and
hopper in imminent danger
so she ditches her sister and heads back
to Hawkins we suspect that Kali will
come back for 11 in season 3 but we
don't know if it'll be for help or
vengeance no matter what happens we'd
love to see hopper become a father of
two powerful girls do you think that
hopper would agree to let Kali live
underneath his roof or will he smell her
intentions from a mile away the talk as
Elevens new guardian hopper is required
to raise her as he would his own
daughter so with this in mind the were
curious to see this character step into
the shoes of fatherhood is no secret
that Mike and xi have a future romantic
relationship sure they might be young
but their characters will be 15 years
old during season 3 of stranger things
doing this knowing this it's a given
that hopper will have to give 11 the
talk and we're curious to see this
awkward fatherly figure spill the tea we
predict that Mike and Elevens
relationship will evolve to the next
level which will undoubtedly make hopper
a little nervous
can you imagine Hopper trying to sit 11
down to warn her about what boys really
wants because we sure can't Season 3
might showcase a great number of
father/daughter moments some of which we
might not be prepared for despite their
young age the kids and stranger things
are growing up before our eyes and so
are their characters we don't know about
you but we're already cringing at the
thought of hopper trying to parents love
triangles if there's one thing that
makes a good show it's a love triangle
and while they're super entertaining to
watch on the screen
they aren't amusing to live out in real
life Johnathan's Steve and Nancy have
been involved in a love triangle for far
too long which is why we expect a new
one to be formed by entirely new people
while it's been confirmed that max and
Lucas will engage in a middle school
romance a lot of fans got the impression
max actually had a crush on Mike in fact
11 herself believed this to be true when
she caused to Max's skateboard to send
her to the floor with this in mind we
think that a love triangle between max
Mike and 11 will ensue speaking of love
we also think that Joyce and hopper will
finally come clean about their feelings
for one another or at least we hope they
will
after losing Bob to the demo gorgon
Joyce will surely be at a loss but
luckily season 3 is said to take place
one year after the events of season 2 so
this might be more than enough time for
Joyce to get over her ex-boyfriend from
what we gather it looks like Hopper and
11 will have their hands full with
relationships if you love a good
tearjerker watch until the end to find
out which fan theory separates hopper
from his daughter once again Hawkins
middle school Hawkins middle school is a
feasting ground for the mind flare which
is why we believe that season 3 will
showcase the learning facility once more
the mind flayer attempted to take over
wills body in season 2 however it was
expelled with the use of heat while it
may look as though this evil force was
defeated we believe that it's simply
retreated with the hope of finding a
brand-new host so who better to possess
then the one and only 11 while this
theory could very well come true we hope
that it won't this is because it might
put hopper in a tight situation since 11
is one of the most powerful beings on
the planet the world would suffer under
her wrath so let's just hope that the
mind player has his eyes set on someone
else 11 is the only person powerful
enough to close the gates to the upside
down so we truly need her on our side
whatever happens you best be sure that
it's going to unfold at the Hawkins
middle school and since 11 will soon be
attending the school it puts her
directly at risk of being used as a host
they always come back if there's one
character we all mutually hate it's dr.
Brenner
aka Poppa this evil scientist kidnapped
and tortured too many children
throughout his professional career worst
of all he convinced 11 that he was her
birth father to get her to carry out
unforgiveable tasks a demo Gorgon mauled
dr. Brenner at the end of season 1
however many of us still believe him to
be alive after all his body was never
showcased so what happened to dr.
Brenner and
will he come back we suspect that he was
experimented on and brought back to life
with some powers of his own during his
absence dr. Owens was given control of
the lab but evidently switched sides by
the end of season two this leaves the
Hawkins laboratory without leadership
which basically butters up the position
for dear old papa
with this in mind we suspect that he'll
come back for his makeshift daughter but
this time he'll have powers of his own
that'll allow him to overpower and
kidnap 11 do you think that dr. Brenner
will worm his way back into season 3
because we're convinced that he will the
test subject takeover we love hopper
which is why we think that he'll make an
excellent father for 11 however we also
believe that hopper will have more
children than he can count by the end of
the season as many of you know handfuls
of children were kidnapped and
experimented on at the Hawkins lab Molly
Levin managed to make contact with eight
there's still a string of other mutant
children running around if dr. Brenner
doesn't fact come back in power he'll do
his best to locate every single one of
his test subjects which will send them
looking for a safe haven we suspect that
children preteens and teenagers alike
will show up at hoppers door and beg for
sanctuary and although he'll be
reluctant at first hopper will do his
best to serve and protect having a house
full of children with numbers four names
won't be an easy thing to master but
with the help of his friends hopper will
prevail despite being an only child 11
will feel as though she's surrounded by
her Ken which will surely bring a smile
to hoppers sullen face operation tarry
finding out that your long-lost mother
is mentally incapacitated is definitely
a letdown especially when you had a
string of questions to ask her when 11
reunites with her mother
Terry Ives she surprised to find out
that she's stuck in some sort of loop
fans believe that season 3 will be
tailored around 11 trying to rescue her
mother's mind but where will she start
could it be that Terry's mind is stuck
in the upside-down causing her soul to
be stuck in two places at once while
venturing through the upside-down 11 saw
her mother and was able to communicate
with her telepathically their banter
caused Terry's nose to bleed proving
that they had a lot in common
despite wanting to save her mother's
mind there might come a time when 11 has
a hard decision to make
save her mother or destroy the
upside-down and everything in it all in
all were certain that season 3 will be
filled with heart-wrenching moments we
just hope that Hopper won't do anything
stupid to reunite 11 with the mother she
always dreamed of history repeats itself
by now we all know that hopper had to
experience something a parent should
never have to go through the loss of
their child although it may have broken
him for some time he was brought back to
life with a new purpose while we believe
that Sarah hopper passed away due to
cancer her actual medical condition was
never stated so some fans think that the
Hawkins laboratory actually victimized
Sara and that her death might have been
the result of unruly experiments on her
person if this is true it might be
possible that eleven will succumb to the
same fate but we're hoping that she'll
be able to fight off whatever comes her
way
in the end hopper already lost one
daughter so we hope that he doesn't have
to go through losing another one
on another note some suspect that dr.
Bruner will infect 11 with a virus which
will force hopper to bring her to the
Hawkins laboratory for treatment
however bringing her here will surely be
comparable to striking a deal with the
devil so which one of these theories
sounds more plausible to you make sure
to let us know in the comments and
that's it for our video thanks for
watching and see you next time on the
things
[Music]